After ignoring the disaster in East
Palestine Ohio for nearly two weeks the
bite Administration now says the area is
totally safe just as long as you're
wearing a hazmat suit or better yet as
long as you don't actually visit it all
the dead fish and the chlorine smell in
the air whatever totally normal your
nose does not know
JD Vance is a senator from the state of
Ohio he's also from Ohio and he had some
questions so he went to East Palestine
which seemed like a pretty simple step a
lot of people can't manage it but he did
and after visiting he challenged the EPA
administer
administrator rather Michael Regan to
drink a glass of tap water
in the town of East Palestine
weirdly Michael Regan has not accepted
that challenge
we are grateful to have Senator JD Vance
of Ohio with us tonight Senator thanks
so much for coming up for coming on I
mean I notice a lot of the people who
are reassuring us about how fine he's
Palestinians don't really want to go
there in fact they've avoided going
there do you think Regan will drink the
tap water
I don't suspect that he will Tucker and
a lot of residents unfortunately are not
comfortable drinking the tap water
either and it's easy not to see why it's
okay the thing that I came away from
after visiting today is that one
residents are very very uh scared
obviously but they are also not getting
answers from their authorities about
exactly what's going on what's being
done to clean up the disaster and on
that point in particular Tucker uh nor
the the the railroad has completely
failed to clean up the toxic soil that's
leaking into the riverways into the
waterways and into the groundwater so
there's this question about testing and
whether we're testing the water enough
the question that I have is why haven't
they cleaned up the contaminated soil
that's going to eventually contaminate
the groundwater no matter what
so you've been criticized for suggesting
that maybe people who are still in East
Palestine drink bottled water and that's
scaremongering because apparently we
should just follow the science and do
what we're told why would someone
criticize you for counseling caution
you know I I have no idea Tucker I I
think that there's a complete refusal to
deal with the fact that a lot of
residents are freaked out on the ground
obviously people want to get back to
their lives they also want to know that
they're safe and the thing that's very
clear if you talk to the EPA if you talk
to the CDC they cannot tell us what a
clean threshold is for the water so on
the one hand you have to measure the
water to know how much of this
contaminant is in it on the other hand
you have to know at what level the
contaminant is low enough that it's
clean water that it's safe for humans to
drink we've been completely unable to
get a good answer from any federal
authorities to that question and if I
can't get that answer and I'm a United
States Senator that suggests that the
people of East Palestine who want to be
cautious have every right to do it the
simple fact is Tucker that unless we go
in and study the effect of vinyl
chloride on human beings we're never
going to be able to say with confidence
what is going to happen to the residents
of East Palestine they want to rebuild
their community they want to get back to
normal life but they can't do it unless
the government does its job
that's right
by the way if you say you're an
environmentalist and care about the
environment you should care about the
air and the soil and the water you know
climate is not the environment um I
would say JD Vance senator from Ohio who
took the time to visit one of his own
communities appreciated thank you